uh joining us once again on the
programme the armed forces minister
james hippie minister great to see you
again um i i wonder if we could start
pretty quickly with the uh security
situation in and around uh kabul
international airport the advice has
changed the time when we know the
flights are numbered there are a finite
number of them left people are being
advised to steer clear of the airport
why is that
uh intelligence over the course of the
week has
become ever more
certain around the
highly credible uh imminent uh lethal
attack onto
the airport or the handling centers
being used by
western forces and in all good
conscience
whilst of course the clock is still
ticking towards the end of the month we
had to share that
very very real threat
with people in kabul and advise them
that
they should move away from the airport
not come to the airport
and i'm aware that that
causes real desperation for many of the
people who are yet to be brought out of
the country but
we're not being overly cautious the
threat whilst i can't give you the
detail
is very imminent very credible very
lethal
can i just then i again i completely
understand your point about not being
able to go into the specifics of the
intelligence where it has come from and
all the rest of it but just to to pick
up in your words there imminent and
critical i mean is there an expectation
that we could within a matter of hours
see an attack on the airport
yes
and
on that basis i i wonder then what can
possibly be done
are we then
limiting ourselves to those who have
already been given permission to get on
a plane are we
essentially how many more flights do we
think we can get out in a situation like
that
well i mean we still have 11 flights
programmed to leave in the next 24 hours
our intention was to continue processing
people
today through the ehc
in reality we have to share the advice
that we've given
but you'll see on your own tv screens
that there are thousands of people that
have um ignored that advice and i
suppose their logic is is that they're
already fearful of their lives um so you
know they've chosen to stay that's
that's not what we would advise them to
do i think it's right that we've told
them that the intelligence is so
credible now and so imminent that we
think they should move away
but we're doing our best to keep those
that have
not left safe
we're doing our best to look at what
other alternative provisions
we might be able to make but obviously
we won't be advertising those because
that would simply make the alternative
routes
a target in themselves
islamic state in the karazhan provinces
is acutely aware of the fact that there
is a closing window for people to leave
that is concentrating people uh in
towards the airport and that is giving
them an opportunity to do something that
they would regard as spectacular
we would regard as absolutely abhorrent
um but it means we have to be very clear
with people what the risks are and we're
doing our best to mitigate them but it's
not we don't have the number of troops
on the ground that we would need to be
able to go off into the city find the
threat and remove it um and that means
therefore we have to
try to operate within the threat
envelope as it is and do our best to get
as many people out as we can at the time
that remains
um i wonder then if you you you'll
probably be aware of the situation
regarding at least one uh british
national pen farthing has been something
i've thought on the mod side over the
past couple of days but he has been
tweeting that he is near to the airport
with his afghan staff the taliban are
not letting him through
he is a british national is there any
argument for putting british troops
outside of the wire to try and get him
and potentially even his staff to safety
so for for him uh i mean
it is
a grim reality of these situations that
uh as a british national we would seek
to
expedite his passage into the airport
but he
commendably has
said that that's not what he wants to do
he wants to bring his staff and his
animals in with them um he's asking us
the americans the taliban for
safe passage but nile i'm afraid as
difficult as it is to say safe passage
is also other words for being brought to
the front of the queue and um i just
wonder
how you feel how your viewers feel um i
know how i feel about having to make a
decision whereby we move lots of
desperate afghans out of the way to
bring him through because
of the the profile and the support that
he has that that doesn't feel like the
right thing to do um it gives me a
pleasure to say that
if
if mr farving's security situation
changes and again i think people will
understand perhaps the position that you
find yourself in but but but should he
have taken the opportunity some days ago
perhaps to to get out on a plane when
when it was there you you yourself said
it the commendable decision to remain
with his staff
till the end but looking at what's
happening in and around the airport
given the security concerns that you
have about isis k i mean that could be a
pretty grim conclusion
he was offered a flight at the back end
of last week i personally
would have wanted to see him on it
because
we've got british troops in danger in
order to facilitate the evacuation of
british nationals and those under the
arab scheme
my secretary of state ben wallace um and
the foreign office have worked very
quickly to get his staff
cleared uh in order to be part of the
leave outside the rules um
visa system and therefore they are
cleared for travel to the united kingdom
um and that is you know that that is now
in place
but the reality is that i i just don't
think that we can move other desperate
afghans out of the way to bring him and
his staff to the front of the queue and
i get it i i served as well and i know
that penn will be applying that
soldier's code of
never leaving your battle buddies behind
and that's how he will regard his staff
um i i wouldn't want to be in his
situation i can see all of the emotion
in everything that he's saying um
but we are in a similarly challenging
situation we've done everything we can
to facilitate his staff coming here uh
we know that he has an aircraft from a
polish operator that he is in
discussions with um we will seek to
facilitate that getting a landing slot
through the combined air operations
center at alude which in in qatar which
is a us
military
facility
but the one thing that we cannot do
is move all of the other afghans out of
the way to let his afghans to the front
of the queue
and i'm afraid it's a hard reality
i i just want to have a couple of uh
questions away from the situation in and
around um in and around the airport
itself um
just in terms of this group isis k it is
not prescribed here in the united
kingdom are there any concerns then that
people who may be affiliated with the
group who may be members of the group
could have somehow made their way uh
through the british
via the british air bridge you know back
to the united kingdom or to any of the
other places that we've been uh taking
uh refugees well daesh is prescribed and
these are just you know these are
affiliates of daesh around the world um
people have um pinged on the uh on the
no-fly list as they've been coming
through checks at the evacuation
handling center at the barron hotel
that i think validates the requirement
for those checks and i know that you
know there are plenty of people who
would say well you know in given the
threat of the
that we're talking about this morning
and it's imminence why don't we just
open the gates and
let people through uh onto the tarmac
and get them all on planes as best we
can in the time that remains but you
know there's there's there's nothing to
say that is haven't preempted that and
haven't got people in the crowd who who
are hoping to be able to sneak through
and access mainland united states or the
uk or somewhere else in western europe
in order to mount an attack so we have
to maintain the checks that we're doing
because that is the uk's front door
right now
and as desperate as the scenes are that
you see on tv there are some really
abhorrent people who are trying to take
advantage of those those conditions in
order to gain access to the us the uk or
some of our allies and um that's the
that's the impossibility of the
situation within which india
are operating
minister we're learning via the
associated press news agency that the
french government has said that after
friday evening they will no longer be
able to be getting people out of the out
of the country i know from a
conversation earlier in the week you do
not want to be very specific but is that
in the rough ballpark of when you're
anticipating uh flights um back to the
united kingdom back to british bases to
end
so our judgment is that we shouldn't um
advertise the end of the evacuation
flights that's for two reasons firstly
that i think actually they sort of take
but we can be bringing out some of the
uh the military and particularly
military kit while still bringing out
people
but secondly
my words the words of my colleagues in
government on your show and other
media outlets in the uk has a direct
consequence
in kabul in terms of the crowds that
gather and the desperation within those
those crowds that's why it's important
to communicate the threat because people
in kabul will be aware of what the
government is saying this morning but
equally if we were to advertise when the
last flights will be
there is a real danger that that causes
a panic that could
cause like we saw last saturday and was
so brilliantly reported by your
correspondent on the ground stewart
ramsey
some truly horrific scenes where people
in their desperation uh cause a crush
that could take life we have to be
responsible in the way that we
communicate
what remains of our plan and then once
the military withdrawal is fully
underway we need to um not offer any
commentary at all on that because as you
would
imagine as each flight leaves fewer
troops remain to secure
at the ground thereafter and they are
therefore ever more at risk as you build
up to that moment when the last flight
leaves so
i'm afraid the ministry of defense needs
to be
um
slightly uh
responsible to our troops and to those
outside in in in not necessarily showing
all the detail that you would want and i
apologize for that no we understand it
mr hippy thanks very much for joining us
really appreciate your time